Look at this crazy AI email from Leila
Hormozi to her internal team, okay? Hey
team, we are bleeding time, period. So,
we're implementing something that sounds
counterintuitive. You're going to spend
1 hour planning to save 10 to 12 hours
executing. Oh, I'm sorry. So, sitting
down for an hour to plan out your week
is counterintuitive. I'm pretty sure
that's been in books for a very, very
long time. It's called Monday hour one.
Oh, did you prompt ChatGPT? Hey, can you
name what 1 hour of planning can look
like and give it something sticky that I
can yell at my people? Starting out
every Monday or Sunday night if you
Sunday night? You want these people to
work on Sundays? Sacred. That's Sabbath.
Oh my goodness. You will block out your
entire week, not some of it, all of it.
Total ChatGPT. Not this, but that. By
Monday morning, your supervisor should
be able to look at your calendar and see
exactly where every hour is going.
You're going to hold their hands? You're
going to You're going to carry them like
babies? This is
Goodness. On Sunday night? Why? Another
ChatGPT. Why? Because this, right?
Always ask a question and then dives in.
Why? Because I can see everyone's time
allocation. I can properly distribute
work and actually hit our project
deadlines. God forbid you miss a
deadline. No No more wondering who's
overloaded. No more hidden capacity.
Just transparency.
Oh, if I didn't read AI copy a million
times, I've seen it there. No more this,
no more that. Just transparency. And
then she does this thing where she had
ChatGPT just like, okay, turn the hour
one into a system where it's like this
and this and this and this and this and
this. And then it comes down where she's
like, your calendar should look like
this. The worst calendar I've ever seen
in my life. Try for 1 week. I guarantee
you'll find hours you didn't know.
Signed, ChatGPT. I mean, Leila Hormozi.